[Musik]
Hauptbahnhof Zürich der Kabarettist
Schriftsteller und Musiker Franz hoher
macht sich auf den Weg in seine
Heimatstadt nach
oldten ich aus Kind immer gern im Zug
gess me Elter hab mir mal verzählt dass
sie so baut Zug h
fahen Freud dass wir jetzt
fahren mit 60
den und und die berühmte
pensionierungsgrenze 6 d mit 7 dan gut
noch bis jetzt ist all
gutang bemerkt ich mit 7 e immer no auf
pensionier gewartet und die einfach nie
und mit 0 sie
einfach aber es ist völlig klar der
Vorrat da Zukunft
[Musik]
schmilzt
im Moment hab ich gar ke literarises
Projekt und das belastet überhaup nicht
zum
Gil danke jetzt zum das ist n größere
Projekt und kann gut vorstellen dass sie
das nicht mehr größer kommt ab
jetzt
dankeemacht
Franz holers Lebenswerk besteht aus 14
Kabarettprogrammen 17 Theaterstücken
etwa 60 Büchern mehreren hundert Fernseh
und Radiosendungen und einem
Spielfilm zum 80 Geburtstag schenkt ihm
seine Heimatstadt gleich mehrere
Ausstellungen dafür werden Manuskripte
bühnenrequisiten und Raritäten aus
seinem Zuhause in Zürich Örlikon in den
Kanton soloturn gebracht
[Musik]
such gerade Text W
mit der Weltuntergang auch in urfassig
der Weltuntergang meine Damen und Herren
dir vom Museum vom historischen Museum
wo wous Stelle und damit Zuber
mus
mit hoffen löpft sie
nicht wie glücklich ist ein Mann wenn er
allein zu Hause
ist
und
halbverbramtes Rindfleisch mit
Spaghetti Resten
ist furchtbar also ihr müsst wirklich
wieder über
ein Essen Z wie Leder aber den nooch
eine
Pracht er hat es
selber gemacht er hat es
selber
gemacht furchtbar das fast poetisch
dön Franz holers Haus ist vollgestoppt
jstbenin Frau der
Psych wurde es oft zu viel des
Guten kte doch im
Garten dra Bau
und das geht
[Musik]
nicht eine Geschichte die
AusstellungsmacherInnen haben die Qual
der Wahl aus der Fülle einen
repräsentativen Querschnitt
[Musik]
zusammenzustellen begonnen hat Franz
hoher seine künstlerische Karriere mit
22 der Erfolg seines ersten
Soloprogramms war für Franz der Auslöser
das Germanistik und romanistikstudium an
der Universität Zürich an den Nagel zu
hängen
[Musik]
für mich sicher sehr wichtig wen ich
aufgewachsen B dass eigentlich musis
elterus aufgewachsen bin mutterpielt
Vater ist Literatur interessiert g
selber viel Text Theater gespielt dass S
z.B Kultur
selbverständlicht alst wird und nicht
Fassade das H glaub
ich wel als freischaffende
fantasiearbeiter sehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
l auch das Film ein kultrequisit aus der
Fernsehsendung Spielhaus soll in oldten
ausgestellt
[Musik]
werden
FE da
sindine es heißt
spielhus
heyis
warum g wieder und
warte
ab den 1980er Jahren führt der Autor
Tobias wies im Spielhaus
Regie da ist dieiste gestanden einfach
nur die Konstruktion einfach in gestellt
mit
demli und da ist
stfunden
der Franz hat geschrieben und der Franz
hat das ganze vrie aber im Prinzip ist
es sehr
passiert Freundschaft al es hat sich
Freundschaft geh und das hat sich
natürlich da bin ich sicher irgendwie
gpel
s ja und das
hatheim Kind und freu gemacht und mir
natürlich auch ma und ih ja ab ma
gr verz und spiele vom aufr das heißt
verz
der Franz da das ist der R das nicht ich
sage
nicht jetzt gich g mit der mit dem
hemli und mit dem Schele W
ich
und sch h ich auch noch
[Applaus]
dazu
über 20 Jahre beglücken Franz und Rönne
kleine und große
Fernsehzuschauer hola arbeitet immer
wieder gerne mit anderen Künstlern zu
einer herausragenden Zusammenarbeit
kommt es Anfang der 1970er Jahre mit
Emil
steinbergerchuldigung
franz
uchig laufen
noch er wird wahscheinlich jetzt mit
Ersatzholz
hamereis so sehen
sch ja er macht das neell mich
nicht
natürlichk
mit dem ne wie freut sich erst ein
frisch gebackener flinker
Ehemann wenn er der Frau den neuen
Kühlschrank übergeben kann er Stöß den
Stecker ein das Kabel raucht der
Anschluss
krachtt er hat ihn selber gemacht der
hab ih selber gemacht
[Musik]
noch heute sind Emil und Franz hoher
befreundet hohers Vielseitigkeit
beeindruckt den Luzerner Kabarettisten
immer
wieder nein so
genial nie also das hat ich der letzte
zit ich schon entdeckt das ist ja
unglaublich was der Franz alles gemacht
und
AG aber auch politisch natürlich auch
sehr starktig wie
das das hat sich bezogen auf auf
chemieumfall V V schweizerhal ist nicht
passiert ist nicht
passiert ist alles wunderbar nur ganz
Spitzel ist der Nebe doch das ist zu
mutbar nur ganzes Spitzel ist der Nebe
das ist schon
zuutbar sie erinner wahrscheinlich am 1
November
186 100 Fisch im R vergiftet wordde die
S grundgang Wasser wo plötzlich zu K mit
Wasser im klassischen
943 Ton
agrochemikaliie 312 Ton sogenannte
formulierhilfsstoffe also was immer das
ist aber
inang gestiftet gefährlich Stoff he aus
der
Produktion also den die Dritte Welt aber
aber da da s ja besser
werden als Restrisiko brennstabs
schmelzen und Natrium brende plötzlich
berstende
reaktorwende
Computerfehler für
erstschlagbefehle und leckende Gase und
Gifte und Öle ist alles hier drin nehmt
ihr alles in Kauf wollt ihr mal sehen
dann mache ich es
auf auf
Wiedersehen
ihr
Restrisiko ha ist einer der ersten
Schweizer Kunstschaffenden der das
Gefahrenpotenzial der Kernenergie
thematisiert er engagiert sich für für
den Umweltschutz mischt sich in den
politischen Alltag ein polarisiert und
wird zur
Reizfigur könnte man nicht den Krieg
überspringen und gleich mit den
Hilfsprogrammen
[Applaus]
anfangen in der Kinokomödie DK shott
kämpft er unter der Regie von Tobias
wies wie ein Don quiijote verbissen
gegen Windmühlen unserer
Zeit los
knleferhe zauberdrick pestbüle vom
juranordf arschb
tüel Problem ist Auffang weg dass mir
nicht gewüsen s da ist das ein großer
Spielfilm oder ist das Miris
improvisiert und der Franz ist ja das
der son RIS und ist ja wunderbar
Improvisator als Schauspieler hat er
einfach ist das ges w er ist und dann
ist der Film hab gemacht
und kin das ist
einigermaßen s Brück das ist
Filmfestival januar und
Publikum
doch und leider ist das nicht das
Schwier fernestt wenn sie gefunden ja
das jetzt
zeigen Ihre Sendung Denkpause zum Thema
Dienstverweigerer auszustrahlen es kommt
[Musik]
zum Danken für kte
W
[Musik]
und
itär
persönlich doch
chloss wir W
[Musik]
noch das Thema wo die
programmverantwortlich vom Fernseh ihr
Zuschauer der Form nichtw
zu sie bewusst
provoziert sie das was jetzt
ja gerade so kan ich nicht W wie jetzt
od mich gar nicht in Politiker und in
satirikerennen sondern m bestreiben ich
eigentlich ganzer Mensch sie und als als
ganzer Mensch meine Sache ausdrücken und
gestalte und das ein lustig sie
satirisch sie das das aber auch ernst
Sie also für mich gehört die zu der
viertel Stunde einfach ein Offenheit wo
groß gen dass so bis ohnees möglich ist
wenn sie Medium schaffen dann wüss Sie
dass Konzession GT und sie K ETW der R
wo die Konzession absteckt also V daher
sie Griem
prz aus Protest wirft her das
Handtuch Jahre später kommt er mit einer
neuen Satiresendung zurück ins
[Musik]
Fernsehen im Theater läuft es für Franz
besser of und gerne kleinater auf in der
heutigen Vorstellung spaziert er durch
sein
gesamtwerkater Luzern ist für mich schon
speziellen Ort das hat der Emil gründet
1967 und hat mich
gefragt
und den und von den bin ich ist das ein
von den Ort g wo ich immer wieder sehr
gern gegangen bin ja und ja und den
hab GT kenneen ich hab ih vorher einlich
im Radio gehört B das Programm g w er
gemacht h da
und
er Sache wo nicht ganz lie und denn
grüid und gratuliert zum Programm h aber
sofort nachher gefragt
du wer hät die Nummer geschrieben und
die num gescheben wer h
ges
das
geschben du musst die num sch weiß das
stimmt so so auf dich zugeschn wie du
spielst und stim
das das das musst du machen und dann h
nur und wenn du mal das Programm schieb
kann sagen wenn ich dir so hfe da komm
ich denn wenn ich mE du num für
michudier dann gibt es mis oder so viel
wie möglich dass der Franz holer eiglich
erste die Zuschauer ist sit einfach da
und ich auf der Büne
sachenenprobieren und
die sind für mich sehr maßgeabend wenn
er lach finde ich SP das Publikum sicher
lachen oder wenn er gar nicht reagiert
wscheinlich ist es schlechte Leistung
von mir ja
männliche in dem das wirklich aus der
Taufe oder aus dem körperus be mir ich
hab vorgestellt ich war
Personalchef wo insat aufg für
autoverkäuf versucht den Autoverkäufer
auf das Inserat kom W das also noch
gemacht Spiel das einfach Z erste Mal
also spiele
probiert ja wie ist ihr Name Brum Herr
Brum ja ja gr Brum WUM zum vornameen WUM
Brum WUM Brum ja ja seltsam Vorname aber
sie sind Schwizer ja ja
das wichtig gut nemen jetzt ne jetzt was
mirich würde interessieren he Gefühl sie
könen überzü DAV Auto kaufen ja sofort
ja ja sch bezüt für
Andes W auf auf Autobranche ja auf
Sektor sch jaw ja also ich meine sie
wsen was KPP ist und
sag K wenn
KF sind
dieerstation
St ein Klassiker aus seinem Repertoire
darf auch in Luzern nicht fehlen ja geil
gerade so schön Bang
Sitze Kön zum Schluss bernutches
Geschicht erzäh es ist war so g
Geschicht aber noch gar nicht so lange
Mittl
sch passiert
ist
oder Schü dur
gochfodt h ü
BZ
zul das hab ich lange nicht GewSt tote
Möger ist ja totale
fantasiesproch
bernut das ist leichtig ich das H herang
W
F das plötzlich der B zum Sch
s was
zel krachtig uf ab sch mon h gchla wie
g h du
ges
mü und romanisch ach W ich die
Nummer da ich voll Lachen wieder
arö find
Mission die Villa Alpina ist über Jahre
dieses KLE in
Zürich
Rückzugsort hier wohnt und arbeitet
er das h glücksf vor 45 Jahr
vorher am See gewt und schon lang m
dem und sie immer Nummer Z oder D geseh
und irgendein ist n da s plötzlich s
Nummer
und nervös morgen wo man
das
ich am Nachmittag
noch der Plan und B Bank gerönt und der
am Schalter W ich gut kennt hab kennt g
bra
Franken für H vielleicht bring ich
morgen wieder zurück wenn ich aber ich
bra jetzt sie
gesagt und was ST denn das Hus der
gesagt
ZL
Z das
richtig ja MS sag Z od den Strahlen über
Gesicht zum lauschigen Garten gehört ein
Holunderbaum der Franz besonders lieb
und teuer ist Nachbarin regul leuch eine
Freundin der Familie assistiert ihm wenn
er mit seinen 80 Jahren auf die Leiter
steigt um für die
die letzten hollunderblüten zu
pflücken ich Ken der Franz und
eigentlich S auf Weltin W sie
inuseminschaft gewohnt miten Elter in
inck am
See ich ja natürlich auch speziell das
der Dimitri und gangen ist nesater
der
die mal erlebt so fester oder oder
wochenendau dazu geführt dass me Vater
der manimater engagiert h und mir der
Schicksalsschlag von me mat sehr nach
mitleibt das ist Gehör meine erste
hheitserinner
auch ich
habe einen jungen Freund mit dem ich
gerne
diskutiere nachts vor allem er ist
gescheit und witzig fasst was
kompliziert ist rasch zusammen und
entlarft was einfach ist als kompliziert
Dichter ist er und mit ihm Metaphern
Wortwahl Versmaß Reime zu besprechen ist
Genuss doch kann ich über menschliches
genauso mit ihm reden über Frau
Sehnsucht Krankheit sorgen Neid und
Zweifel und wir können lachen wie die
Kinder er ist schon mehr als 5
Jahrzehnte 36 Jahre alt seit jenem Abend
auf der
Autobahn se kennt das ist der manimat
und er hät übrigens sie solo
Programm zum erste Mal nichtn fürt
sondern da imater
Emil Frage so bracht
[Musik]
dams es muss noch für die letzte Portion
holdersup
aber noch nicht
fertig
okay überhaupt nicht
nervliche viusig bestick unter anderem
bit Bernina über biankograt und
überhaupt nicht schwindelfrei die L aber
flatter lassen wir noch
her der Holder gilt eigentlich
als aus schutzpflanze und zwar g
Blitzschlag ah ja ja und es geht
ein grimisches Wörterbuch das ist das
größte Wörterbuch von der deutsche
Sprache hol h altername des Holunder ne
ich so schließ sich Kreis so schließ
sich Kreis regul wohnt mit ihrer Familie
im selben Haus wie das Ehepaar
holer sie sind junge mir sind
Kind das sind mir die junge g jetzt
großind und dass die Geschichte wirklich
bis 80 gegangen ist das
ist recht faszinierend und jetzt
Generation vor der Adina mit dem Jell
wenn die
beideell Spiel den ich meistens am Büro
vorbereit fürsk und KST
so zwei am Spiele sind Adina ist die
elfjährige Tochter seines Sohnes Kaspar
Großvater und Enkelin üben jede Woche
gemeinsam aber du musst
stimmpiit sell ja gut
und 1 2 3 4 1 so ja 1 2 3 4
[Musik]
ein
SP muss Spiel bevor es mit mir
Spiel
aber generell kann er B
[Musik]
Spiel gar nicht
schlecht
ganz gut
gemacht ja ich kan l vor der tell ST
kannich besser
werden aber er Verl immer Not
blitter aber noch nicht da super ist gut
das ist
auch hab schon kopier sie immer wieder
verlt ewig lange pizicato ist mir gut do
ke
pizato gezupft gezupft aber ist kein
pizato es heißt giche aber ist egal es
GT ja meh um tönum Wort aber das machst
du
ganz Wort
ord um Mord ja ein Z
[Musik]
fast gur gut
gen nächster Halt
Olten
ja genau
bahnhofsü ja genau berümte
genauity 61
na jeder Besuch in seiner Heimatstadt
löst bei Franz holer positive Gefühle
[Musik]
aus da
über Brück laufen auf Altstadt überl ist
immer das
[Musik]
heicho
wachsen wnen aber schon länger
n und rückblckend Li
geschrieben heißt und
[Musik]
umwoch
mit her Sinfonie komponiert sie schön
nur zum Spiel
sch in diesem Haus wuchs Franz zusammen
mit seinem älteren Bruder Peter
auf ich B so interessiert g Bücher dass
sie n bevor Bücher les bin ich da
malt das fjährige will wahscheinlich
irgend BU V wi obwelle fen und was
passiert
ganz
ganz ganze Regals ganze Bücher gestellt
kippet Bücher ke über mir aber ke da
unter aber unter schribtisch und das ist
der Hick wo man hü noch seht waso
Büchergestell geschlag h ich riptisch
und wenn der schtisch nicht W dann hat
mE erschlag Bücher unds Büchergestell
hat mir a fünjährige
erschlagen im Historischen Museum Olten
rückt die Eröffnung der Ausstellung
näher Etage
3 das schön wegen ausstellungswechsel
geschlossen ist natürlich schön wenn
sagusstelligswechsel bin
ich guten
[Musik]
Morgen letzte Besprechung mit den
AusstellungsmacherInnen also
die
woher ja aus me Programm im Turm zu
Babel stell wo einel angesprochen worden
ist im Himmel und noch bekannt das
Himmel und hö jetzt fusioniert damit me
Synergie möglich sie möchte mit dem
Chef gesftsre ja und was
g sind abgewiesen worden ja das sind sie
nichtzig was hat dann der ausschlage
wenn ich fragen darf ein feldtritt mit
ein andere Frau ja sie das sch mal
geleistet ja ja lass sie jetzt hol sie
ein von der erzel Formular f d sie das
sorgfältig ausfüllen Reich S rekursangel
und er wird dann der wiederwommission
vorle ja hat schon ja hat rech
pendenzberg ja und der Vorsitz hat der
heilig
stagnatius da vielleicht noch Wied der
im Heft berühmte Schweizer jawoh ja ist
das es Schulheft oder ist das das
privatft
V selber für mich gemacht W mir das
interessiert
h
Gefühl ich darfen
oder das die
Primarschule general GIS und in hab ich
noch fotografiert und zwar W al über
bahnhofbrück vor s ja dass er kommt und
B auf der lur mit dem
fotaaratch dass keine Uniform h aber das
ist nicht da z vor
rechts ich gegenüber vom historischen
Museum befindet sich das Kunstmuseum
Olten hier tritt Franz holer als Kurator
in Erscheinung aus den Beständen der
Kunstsammlung hat er seine
Lieblingsbilder
ausgewählt Arbeit empfindet holer als
etwas
Positives Arbeit als Freud wenn immer
möglich od natürlich gibt's Moment wo
man erpresst wird dur zitdruck aber
Arbeit an sich
ich für mich es Glück mit der Klasse
zammenkünft S blutter
ehemalige chefärzt und Zahnärzte
Zahnärzte also Kim oder ehemalige Lehr
oder wo eigentlich schon lang könenen
obwohl s sicher gern gemacht und
mir ich sber bestimmen wenn ich hör und
H eigentlich immer a Privileg empfunden
dass S noch dass ich noch witer
schaffe du darst das jetzt schon so al
Werte Erle ich auch die Moment
wo wo Sache wo ich ganz früher gemacht
hab mir völlig LEBIG g W sie immer
nochfragt S und ich ja gut vielleicht
das viicht BBT das
nochfagt sagen wir Ballade vom
waltuntergang von
1973 die ist 50 Jahre alt und
der wird
aber wird aber die gegenwärtige
Situation vom Klima wird jetzt z einen
aktuellen Text oder da kratzen sich die
Wissenschaft meistens in den Haaren sie
sagen in 10 in 20 Jahren in 50
vielleicht oder auch in
100 ich selber habe mich anders besonnen
ich bin sicher der Weltuntergang meine
Damen und Herren hat schon
begonnen in Ihrem Garten treffen sich
Franz und Ursula regelmäßig mit den
Familien ihrer beiden Söhne Lukas und
Kaspar Enkelin Adina bereitet schon mal
das Terrain für den gemeinsamen Brunch
vor kom immer wieder
WASP freuen wenn wenn Familie kommt od
das ist sehr schön mit Familie
undkelind und
man man das L wi
[Musik]
Gott
hey
[Musik]
H
oder auch
was
hora sprach und spiel mit der sprach ist
immer natürlich um umie ich merk jetzt
natürlich sehr wo wo ich mit der KA
zammen bin
wo Kenia ist wo man so R und das hat in
sofortfang interessieren ja was ist das
für sprach hat
sichkundig
du mir viicht Material bringen oder
K
und vor zi Wochen ist meine Frau vi
geworden und ist dann spech W
macht und der speech auf Swahili da
speech aufahilialt und hat alle
überrascht sehr gut sagar oderar
und wenn der Z Mal seit byes dann weiß
ich dass seit morgen
morgen probier Konjugation merken und fr
Singular Plural und so weer die
sacheatisch ist effektiv ein
Perfektionist und das sag jetzt mal das
trib Blü od sich verschiedentlich B Orgs
verletzige zuzogen will irgendwie in dem
Perfektionismus z.B von der
olivenflasche will da olivenölfasche der
metalling lös und
sicher in dum gefahren ist das ist fast
Z klassig Word dass irgendwelche und den
hüfig sinnigerwies vor irgendwelchen
Auftritt mit
chell das
Problem oder oder dass er auch got das
orgen
ist
ja ist z Thema wo immer wo wo mir ist
den lustig macht drüber also das alles
korrekt muss entsorgt werden oder
andersit auch und das bis jedes winzige
essensr den irgendwie Mini Topper
Kühlschrank wander da W nur olivfürig
ist das ist den viicht vom
Perfektionismus wo ja sag mal so W ich
jetzt nicht Teile oder dann vielleicht
schon
fast man
über
Z der goldige Hochzeit W man ja zuem
schreckf doch du gesagt du MS gar nicht
so
lang Hälfte von derit
Weg s das wahinlich Sil
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]
Dash
Fam fern SP
[Musik]
frauch ist einfach nicht anders
Gang
n sie so
[Musik]
n welche Erinnerung haben die Söhne
trotz seiner häufigen
Abwesenheit schwer zum sagen er ist im
Hintergrund g aber es ist nicht so dass
er nicht präsent g wä oder
nichtsprechbar es ist frag der Familie
glaub
so immer wieder Situationen z.B ich sehr
liederschaftlich gestritten Hand und
Franz und Kasper sind
dann
[Musik]
Schachspiel also holund das ist running
J daso sind das und alsober
gemacht bis bis in gestalte wo wo ja wo
Teil von bemüh alles Stück perfekt
machen od oder auch schöne Welt kreier
sag wir mal doch das macht alles nicht
sol lang Sommmer ist und sitzt lange
tich und jetzt mit der Kamera bitte
schwankkm Schnitt aber jetzt machen wir
schwankk we R auf Sommergetränk auf
Sommergetränk
Schw Getränk wei Gott aber wenn ich
plötzlich meh für holdersirup
interessier fürs Welt geschehe denn merk
ich da dass es Summer wird den ist z V
der Glassen und Shake V der holzkolgill
und der hrück Steak Kind fröhlich aus
der Schul und
bundesverfassestuhl
in oldten besucht Franz hoher die
christkatholische Kirche hier war er in
seiner Jugend oft
engagiert ich B zwar nicht gläubig aber
finde K wichtige Funktion h nämlich ein
Ort wo man jedere Stadt einfach in sitze
und
denke und K muss immer auf für die
benachteiligte da
s musiziert hat Chor begleitet oder
habich solostückpielt oderammen mit
derurel und von der Sakristei h man
hinter Altar gesehen und Altar vorne
wunderbar
brokatck strahanz und Tabernakel
etc und hinter ist einfach
putzüelestanden mitbürste und der ganz
unverputzt
od so
gat vorne und was ist hinter Altar und
das Bild ich mir immer
wieder ich mir B ganz V
undü auf der der
Kche fr ausgestellt hier kann die
weitgehend unbekannte Seite von ihm als
Fotograf und Chronist des Alltags
entdeckt werden das das der
Hund vom
Nachbar und mit dem mit vpfot
measchine ja aber W
man Wied
gerichtet
wo am See gewohnt und das ist dur Frau
ja und das ist dor Meer das Frau vom
Schriftsteller Gerhard Meer wo der Kiosk
in nerpip Betrieben
h das der lukaster Sohn W bur und das H
ich das da ich Mord auf der Laube ja
das ist von ich weiß nicht
genau wie wie ist der Z aber der irgend
Spiel gemacht am Schluss der müss
glauben ja es ist schonrücklich also ich
Gefühl ich war nicht 80 sondern
160 wenn ich wenn ich l was was
Platz
oder
[Musik]
andre
melichll
Destination aber das wo man extra maacht
für sie das sie noch nicht se auf dem
Bus
nein da geht und der Bus der Fahrt also
bis im November
Fahrt die lieben Schülerinnen wo da
jetzt kommen haben vom halben Jahr zum
totenmel diese Zeichnungen gemacht
undoll
uneding gr gut also Rück
nocham machen wir das
so natürlich auch ja
Bravo in Ihrem Garten blickt Franz
zusammen mit seiner Frau Ursula auf
seine Anfänge zurück und zieht Bilanz W
jung hab ich mir zwei Biographie zurecht
Geleit und die ein ist
g studiere wird der
mittelschulhr und du denn
viicht schrieben und so und die zweite
Biografie ist geh ich probiere mit
meinen Idee und von meinen Idee Z Leben
und für die zweite Biografie hab ich
mich entschieden mit 22 und B zum
Studium
ausgestiegen und wenn ich jetzt
zurückle muss ich sagen freut's mich
auch dass mir das gelungen
ist
so jetzt kommt
Endprodukt vom
holdersirup jetzt der Flasche der
holdersirup der
holderer der Holder wo man
abgen 24 Stund im Wasser Liter Wasser
dann nimmt man hold
Blüte
und mit
dem Kilo wise Zucker
aufkochen bis jetzt ist einfach eine
normale Flasche gie und wenn ich die
Flasche den verschenke z.B mache ich
noch
kineine Zeichn
drauf ja
daes
hasslich hässliche Barcode W
wegbringe jetzt machen wir doch da auch
Kunst dusus ja
voila da wär wir alles selber
[Musik]
gemacht
das gar nicht schlecht m